yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing doom ICC so yeah I have to check
those lines yeah this is an interesting
line that I definitely need to check
this is recommended in that book by
David Cummings for white of English
opening repertoire book and I have not
yet checked it right age 5 in this
position that is uncommon yeah Ethel f5
f5 young wealth night h4 is the Vista is
the issue with this kind of move we
might have Knight f4 actually huh right
f4
yeah I just grab stuff I mean I'm not
going to ignore the all this material
here it's a big big poem and gives me
another pawn which I have to take it
doesn't work simply I mean just going to
get mobile right now I don't know people
don't don't know that opening simply
here the Petrosian it's such a it's out
of fashion and they play whatever and
then down directly in trouble
what I mean with whatever is stuff like
that which is I don't know maybe this is
okay but it feels strange Nigel for is
the normal and tlk I mean if you now
avoid at five maybe maybe effort yeah
this is a typical thing I'm actually
surprised that f5 is played immediately
because I mean g3 isn't it's very
typical it stops 9 f4 and it attends
night h4 + f5 is kind of saying you know
school you we have you ideas with
nothing and night h4 is just good for
Wyatt in especially with this that it
loses instantly basically and over I'm
this pawn up Blake structure is dead I
get the e4 square and so on and this is
just additional material
[Music]
that's it that's actually sort of funny
move somehow it's an even exchange for
for basically nothing but it's so kind
of funny and to take I made if I take
with the Queen
I even that winter I'm pairing this
intermediate move okay guys thanks for
watching